Long ago, the four nations lived
together in harmony.
Then, everything changed when the
Screw this. I'm going back in the ice.
Good show.
Anyways, hello. This is Jim with Next
Level Commander. Believe it or not,
Eldrazi are actually arguably one of the
most under-explored tribes in all of
Magic. Have I been smoking?
No, not this time. Am I trying to shock
and bait you into watching the first 30
seconds of my video?
Possibly, but hear me out. So, by
under-explored, I mean how explored it
is in relation to its potential, to the
amount of possibilities available. If
you've ever played against a colorless
Eldrazi deck, you will know it's
actually a really freaking powerful
show, chaining rocks into rocks, and now
they have Zulodok. It single-handedly
recoups all of that lost card advantage.
It's pretty powerful. Now, I'm not too
familiar with anything above bracket
three, but I believe a tuned Zulodok
probably probably low bracket four at
least. But, what's interesting about a
powerful colorless shell is that you can
play it with over 3,000 legendary
creatures. Yeah, literally every single
one of them. Yet, are people trying
anything beyond the most obvious
choices? EDH Wrecks says not really.
Now, to be fair, is anything here
actually stronger than Zulodok or say
Ulamog? Probably not. Not too sure
there. But, can we find something more
interesting? Perhaps more suitable for
bracket three?
I think so. Well, it turns out we have
one today, Monk Gyatso.
Eldrazi. I bet you've never seen this
one before. Gyatso is such a sweet card.
I glanced over this many times.
Excellent in the 99, not a great
commander was my verdict. Because, I
mean, what can you do with this? ETB or
some kind of combo? But, there are way
better commanders for both. Say, what is
something Gyatso can do that Brago
can't? Well, Gyatso does cast the
spells, but what creatures benefit from
being cast? Oh,
right. So, yeah, with the right setup,
Gyatso will allow us to recast over and
over again, getting those sweet
triggers. And it's not just that, Gyatso
actually works really well with
face-down creatures. Manifest, manifest
dread, cloak, all that stuff. Because we
can drop them, target them, and then
they become usable from exile. This is a
great alternative way to cheat in the
big boys, but they don't even have to be
creatures, either. Imagine an Air Bender
Ugin, Air Bender All Is Dust. Lands
don't work, though, so don't Air Bend
those. And it turns out Eldrazi actually
have a lot of inherent synergy with
morph. There's even a Kozilek like that
lets us morph stuff from hand. Imagine
this, you morph a few things, Air Bend
them, cast Air Bend Kozilek, cast
repeat. Okay, this is actually really
synergistic. This is sweet. Let's go,
and this time we start with the exciting
part, the Eldrazi. We actually don't
need many, just the most exciting ones.
Even 11 might be a bit high. I'm not too
sure about Artisan of Kozilek, for
example. I guess it's decent, but we are
ramping our way up with Oblivion Sower,
the Solemn Simulacrum for Eldrazi, and
we'll get to use it over and over again.
Conduit of Ruin is also an early drop
that can set us up for the next turn
perfectly. Okay, enough with the chump
blockers already. Here comes the titans.
I'm going to rank them for this deck,
but I would say Ulamog, the Defiler is
probably the weakest. I mean, it's still
ridiculous if I drop it on say turn five
and it sticks, but that probably won't
be happening too often, and I don't
benefit too much from the cast trigger.
So, yeah, this is definitely not the
best for this particular deck. And next
up is Ulamog, the Infinite Gyre. Sweet
card, nostalgic. But, yeah, just blowing
up one thing now isn't quite enough in
this economy. Next up is Emrakul, the
World Anew. It's a sweet ability, but
doesn't synergize too well with our
deck. Are we really going to Air Bend
this and sac our board including Gyatso?
I mean, in fringe cases, maybe, like in
response to a board wipe, but generally,
no. Next up is Ulamog, the Ceaseless
Hunger. Exiling two things is definitely
worth doing over and over again, and the
attack trigger can ruin someone in two
to three attacks. Above that, we have
Kozilek, Butcher of Truth. Kozileks are
the Eldrazi that work best with
colorless because when we dump ramp into
ramp, the refill is absolutely clutch.
Better than the Butcher is Kozilek, the
Great Distortion. This is the Eldrazi
you feel most comfortable tapping out to
cast because it will protect you. And
your opponents kind of have to dance
around it. But, the best Kozilek, in my
opinion, for this deck is the Broken
Reality. It can draw you four cards
while disrupting your opponents a
little. And recasting this over and
over, you can actually run them out of
cards, which is ridiculously powerful.
Or alternatively, we can use this to
morph two things from our hand, which
will then Air Bend and cast for cheap.
And finally, the ultimate EDH Eldrazi,
Emrakul, the Promised End. Yes, this
card wins games, especially if you
trigger it multiple times. I can even
target the same opponent over and over
again with the help of flash, but
usually one properly timed return is
more than enough. And that's all the
Eldrazi. Now, we move on to the subtheme
of the deck, face-down shenanigans.
Seriously, if you're building this deck,
don't sleep on these morph cards. It
might sound a bit gimmicky, but in
practice, it works really well.
Unsettling Twins, for example, I was
really disappointed with this being the
best white manifest dread card, but even
this turned out to be an all-star in the
deck. Play it, cheat in one card from
the top, Air Bend it, Air Bend the twin,
repeat. It's a value engine. Ugin's
Mastery is sweet as well, and of course,
Scroll of Fate. Also, there's Ugin, the
Ineffable. I do also play Unexplained
Absence because it's just a really good
removal spell. But, yeah, that's it. I
thought we'd have more manifest cloak or
manifest dread options considering I
mean, we have three freaking keywords
for the same thing, but apparently not.
Okay, now, a final hurdle before that
sweet, sweet value. We need ways to
target our own stuff. For that, I'm
trying to stick with lands and mana
rocks with that ability rather than
playing cards to do just that. There are
some decent options. The best of the
bunch are Tower of the Magistrate and
Northampton Farm. We'll also have to
make do with stuff like Endless Sands,
Ruin of Oren Reef, Eye of Ghet, Tyrant's
Sanctum, and even Secluded Starforge.
Also, these MDFCs can Air Bend in a
pinch. In mana rocks, I'm using
Liquimetal Coating and Patriarch's Seal.
The Iron Craig is just a decent mana
rock, and when I'm really desperate,
I'll consider the option to turn it into
an equipment and Air Bend things for
three mana each. But, yeah, that reminds
me, equipments are also excellent for
that, especially Lightning Greaves.
Swiftfoot Boots also makes the cut. We
do need protection for Gyatso, and also
Stoneforge to search for them.
Collector's Cage is a hidden gem that
allows us to target things repeatedly,
but it's also just a sweet value card.
Often times, you just get to dig five
cards and cast one of them for free.
Also, an aura and Sentinel's Eyes being
reusable from the graveyard for one mana
makes it really efficient. But, the best
of the bunch is none other than
Triskelion. Yes, I broke Triskelion. It
doesn't really combo too well in this
deck, but it's still insane value. Every
time it pings, something gets Air Bent,
including itself. So, even just on its
own, it's two mana for two damage, which
can be useful because it's repeatable.
And because of Gyatso, our entire board
is pretty much protected from spot
removals. But, what about the old man
himself? We don't play too many ETB
creatures, but the ones we do are mostly
for protecting him. Guardian of the
Faith is the best of the bunch, phasing
out Gyatso while Air Bending any number
of other creatures. Aether Adept does
the same, pretty much. And Aven
Interrupter is disgusting when we get to
use it over and over again. Restoration
Angel and Salvation Swarm are less good,
but still pretty useful and versatile.
I'm also using the best protection
spells like Teferi's Protection, Dawn's
Truth, and Cosmic Intervention. These
are not just for Gyatso, but also
because we tend to overcommit with our
artifact ramp. For removals, aside from
the aforementioned Unexplained Absence,
we've got three Ugins.
Yeah, they're just all really good.
Final Showdown is ridiculous. I try to
put it into every white deck, and it
fits perfectly here. Austere Command is
still stable status. That's a lot of
answers. Somehow, this mostly colorless
Eldrazi deck has more answers and
utility than most of my other decks.
Yeah, and we have some generic Eldrazi
colorless enablers like Vedalken Orrery,
Skittering Surveyor, and Liberator.
Flash is huge in this deck. Imagine
having a bunch of Air Bent cards and you
can just fire them off at any time for
two mana each. Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Strionic Resonator for some copying, and
of course, Echoes of Eternity. And of
course, we have a lot of ramp as Eldrazi
decks do. Nothing too special here, just
all of the most efficient rocks. And
also, we have a Tezzeret just for the
soaring and occasionally the mana vault
shenanigans. For lands, we prioritize
targeting with the ones we mentioned
earlier. But, aside from that, we do get
to enjoy more utility lands than most
other decks, starting with ramp, some
miscellaneous utility, and of course, my
personal favorite, Winding Canyons. Just
imagine having a bunch of Eldrazi on Air
Bend, a Winding Canyon, and some open
mana. What do your opponents even do?
But, yeah, there you have it, Gyatso
Eldrazi. This deck is sweet because it's
multi-dimensional. You are capable of
ramping out big Eldrazi on turn four or
turn five, but you can also play the
morph manifest game to cheat them out.
Gyatso ties it all together, and there's
so many interesting interactions and
cool plays to be explored. The deck is
really explosive. I mean, look at the
mana rocks. But, in exchange, it's not
the most resilient. White does help a
bit, but you still risk losing half of
your mana base to a board wipe. Card
draw can also be a little bit rough if
you don't find your Kozileks in time.
It's not the most difficult deck to
play, but there are a lot of
interactions and decision trees that you
will have to figure out. Eldrazi decks
are not cheap. Archidekt shows just shy
of $1,000 for the cost, which is
to be fair, lower than what I had
expected, but the expensive pieces are
kind of important. And I mean, half of
them are the Eldrazi themselves. So,
yeah, and finally, this should be
suitable for most bracket three tables.
Might even be higher depending on what
your group is used to.
But, that's all. Thank you for checking
out another deck tech. I've been really
into deck techs lately. These ideas just
keep coming. You can check out my
Archidekt. Oh, yeah, and the list for
this deck is also down below. But, check
out my Archidekt page. You can see what
I'm toying with, and if any of them
looks interesting to you, do subscribe.
I will make a video on that, probably.
That's all. Thank you. I will see you
soon.